[موسيقى] أكثر
ما أحبه حقًا
في تواجدي في المطبخ هو أنني
أشعر أن بقية العالم
غير موجود
، وأنا في منطقة راحتي
وأتمكن من اللعب باستخدام
وسائط مختلفة  قوام مختلف
وجرب فقط
اسمي نادية باريك وأنا
طاهية معجنات هنا في ميلانج
دبي ولدت وترعرعت هنا ، لذلك كان هذا
المنزل دائمًا
وأتذكر دبي مختلفة تمامًا عندما كنت
أكبر مما هي عليه
الآن  أعتقد أن أحد الأشياء التي
استمتعت حقًا
بتطورها في هذه المدينة هو
مشهد الطعام
، إنه يشبه إلى حد ما لندن بهذا
المعنى حيث يمكنك العثور على طعام من جميع
أنحاء
العالم وهو أمر جيد كما لو كان يتم بجودة
ولكن أعتقد  ما تمتلكه دبي هو ذلك
الدافع والموهبة التي تجذبها إلى
أنها تتمتع حقًا بالقدرة
على التواجد
هناك ، سنطلق صندوق تذوق الكعك
عبر الإنترنت مما يعني شريحة واحدة من
كل نكهاتنا الست
بالنسبة لي عندما أكون  تصميم كعكة يجب
أن يتناسب مع
الجمالية  التصميم الذي أميل إليه بشكل
طبيعي وهو عبارة
عن قوام مختلف ووسائط مختلفة ،
يجب أيضًا أن آخذ في الاعتبار ما
يريده العميل
، وهو الزواج من الاثنين معًا
وإيجاد هذا التوازن ، فإن
هذه المنطقة بشكل عام تحب حقًا
قهوتهم مع شريحة من شيء ما  حلو ،
هناك الكثير من
متاجر الحلويات والمقاهي المختلفة التي ظهرت بها معجنات جيدة حقًا
قبل ظهور الحلوى في دبي ، حيث كان هناك نوع من
التغاضي عن
الناس يركزون عليها
أكثر بتوظيف طهاة معجنات أكثر مهارة
مع مزيج وأعتقد أن ما
هو السحر هو أننا "  أعد
التركيز حقًا على الكعك وأعتقد أن العثور على
هذا
المكان المناسب وقبول حقيقة أنك
لست سيدًا للجميع
ولكن يمكنك فعل شيء واحد أفضل
من
الآخرين وأنت فقط تركز على ذلك وتذهب
معه